this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
palette everybody's favorite Gary
Brannen Gary Brannen it's me oh I see I
see you get the warmup time
did you set that up while we were
outside wish I did it and standing in
for Matt gray please welcome stand-up
mathematician Matt Parker pleasure to be
your replacement in front of me I've got
an article from Wikipedia and these
folks can't see it every fact we get
right is a point and a ding and a
special prize for particular answers
which is oh that's the right underneath
that one come Matt fill in for the
classy panel show and today we are
talking about Turku I don't know it sort
of who you know I figured I'd at least
know what the words you're saying are
the language is Doric okay Aberdeen
always right oh thank you Aberdeen sure
north east Scotland it's a particular
dialect yes you are absolutely right
near the Aberdeen sure town of tariff
I'm Tara is tariff okay what might cool
would be pigeons cattle it's infield oh
yeah
just working out they had a big enough
population for a hostile takeover that
is it
no you're absolutely right the Turku is
director for the terrific cow were you
not expecting a joke you just make your
cheap joke at the expense of Scots
darling know what absolutely right I
know you know somewhere between like a
nonzero amount of things about a lot of
things each dairy cow you know I'm like
okay I'm out
welcome to um the cow became famous
Britain's Got Talent
did it juggle how it's got four legs of
no arm
he's size on his back and does that I
was gonna it was sat on an office chair
or any other turn could do it just so
happened its act was on an office chair
well that means you can slide it onto
the stage because I don't propel itself
cause it's little legs are stuck out
forwards oh you think I'm being
ridiculous but actually I've just
produced a very good way of transporting
a cow sat down at last I like the idea
that there would be notation for a cow
juggling with four limbs there would
sure you could
well somebody's written the patents cuz
it boring juggler information
brace yourselves here he comes oh it's
how gandini patents work that's
effectively one these two people using
four arms to juggle one pattern and the
siteswap notation
they mathematically predicted new
juggling tricks that had never been
juggled before because the mass worked
out and then there were like oh it works
my goodness right and so mathematically
you can predict ways to juggle without
ever having to bother to learn or pick
the balls up it's great
so Turku yeah
the juggling cow of reality
this was definitely before Britain's Got
Talent it is a x-factor PT by pop idol
yeah opportunity knocks for the students
in the audience yeah you're you're
certainly closer this this was Aberdeen
sure um this was under the under a
Liberal government and liberal with a
capital L there okay so that is pre
David Lloyd George probably we're
talking liberal wig territory it was
actually I'm gonna give you the points
you gave the name David it was David
Lloyd George as Chancellor of the
Exchequer oh my god that's nineteen
eleven yeah you're absolutely right on
the points again uh it was I have it
down here with the 1910 but the specific
reference um what did he bring in
finance finance valuation act pensions
and the unemployment benefit the
Parliament act I'm a missed them all the
first cow that could retire with a safe
pension Gary the point it was it was
national insurance company yeah yeah no
three squirts for you one for the taxman
for all workers between sixteen and
seventy so is that it was the national
insurance yeah okay and the farmers
local two tariffs were not happy about
this because they would have to pay
their employees nothing sure understand
the contributions were too high yes
absolutely right it was unfair for them
to pay for something they were unlikely
to use unlikely they're very likely
there are think it's a bother might not
get to bench Miller who Beasties kill
very much yeah in mortal dairy workers
less in mortal peril than some other
people in that era who might have been
more at risk a trick people working in
the dairy mines yeah I'm a big cream
seems rich rich seem of you just receive
a squirt even go back
Oh more they're sort of drilling it's
like we've struck cream gotta go
faces white takes the glasses up a safe
route things apart from the word daryun
there you're absolutely right so I'll
give you the point it's people who would
work in the mines in an industry so
there were protests and what did one
particular farmer refuse to do I no
doubt it involves this cow no not yet
no yeah the cow was later in evolved
this cat it will later involves careful
not can you point the back that's bloody
obvious yeah did they March somewhere uh
that was happening but we're looking at
one specific person was doing as a civil
disobedience they can't just be he
wasn't just refusing to make the
payments so it must be something
creative it was stamping the insurance
cards it was it was doing the paperwork
required but that may be the most boring
answer to a query like that we need to
get through this that's how we resisted
this stuck his quill in the farmyard and
wrote it on with that Oh was it a pro
related process that we handed that no
it was it was literally he just refused
to do this so he was he was charged he
was sentenced to pay 15 pounds plus the
arrears which no it's not a small amount
of money I probably caught hundred quid
actually in today's terms oh yeah dyrdek
like to take his cow ah sheriff's
officer George Keith turned up as a
bailiff essentially and looked round for
property that could be seized and when
this cows in a chair already I think
it's real astray out of the farmyard see
yeah that cows worth a lot future
earnings a lot this is getting a bit
Jack in the Beanstalk so far it is a
little bit of sheriff sees the cow okay
the trouble is now the government owns a
cow wait we've got the National cow it
was set to be sold yes what's the slight
problem with that I don't know bugger
buy it absolutely right oh boy not only
that not only that no local Mart no
local agricultural Mart would handle the
sale so now the government still has a
cow
who's not out hungry it's a coach has a
boy cow or a girl cow
it's a girl okay I believe that's
technically a term for that
yes it's cow I only know that because I
made that same mistake myself citizens
found the cow tied in the village square
and decorated with a slogan lend room to
leeks Landrum is where they were why
might that have been the slogan it's
making a reference to someone so
lloyd-george why would the hose Welsh
there's the police yes yes yes that's a
nice bit of stereotype I just sauntered
into there isn't well this was this was
being done by the sheriff as there as
the victor this is we have taken your
cow we are tying it in the square we
can't sell it but it's not your cow
anymore what was the what was the
response to this barbecue no they liked
the cow they wanted to keep the cow you
can like it and be it be delicious don't
even close to being mutually exclusive
they brought in loads of other identical
cows now you'll never tell which way I'm
painting than one three and four so are
they for number two different hats over
then do like a three cow Monte well
under one of these cups off the ground
no I go to Vegas in doing that I've ever
fought you know there was a near riot
okay the answer there was a hundred
strong mob pelting the sheriff's offices
with rotten fruit and sort we don't do
that these days do we we don't get riled
up over minor issues to this also very
hard to get some fresh vegetables these
days a safari you have a through nose at
Waitrose for those open allotments are
you you know the best you can do is like
Amazon one-hour delivery and even them
the Sherry's probably caught and on and
liked it as it is
from Amazon protest the kids are
brilliant anything that goes out a day
send it for flinging
and it could be good because it's over
real brick that could send you in those
rubble ones so you make the same point
but no one gets hurt
but you can still do the same thing
you've just you know you put someone
else's address in and a delivery
instructions say please throw through
window fill this is drifting toward
Amazon drones to a drone strike Joe Joe
drone general strike like three people
got back really good agency thank you
you can do it can send people bees can't
you in the post you can send ants
definitely yeah I've heard through the
letterbox one at a time please
individual packaging once you've sent
the first one through the others will
probably follow well know George would
submit to a lot of protests anyway won't
be over this I think it's over women's
suffrage but they that they planted a
bomb outside his house at one point and
my favorite one is they they cut his
braces lady came up behind snapped his
braces at his trousers fell down for the
non-uk audience that's that's like
suspenders the things that holy trousers
things on his teeth with wire cutters
between four seven in the UK Lloyd joy I
need no scandal around him not to say
suspenders okay that's true so amidst
the malloc there is a cow with a slowly
winning with a slogan page on the side
there are the sheriff's officers and now
an angry rioting mob what happens during
this I'm right in the cow is used in
some way as part of the mob maybe to
head it off or a battering ram Auto be
sheep no the cow escapes it's a bid for
freedom this is what they want it's got
it's just gone flat edge of organized
protest
it's a Benny Hill yeah yes the cow was
later found it in a nearby barn eight
farmworkers were put on trial in
Aberdeen for disorderly conduct
nice charge all the people put on trial
requited why what was the verdict they
were given ultimate lulz that is not a
valid Scots verdict but something else
is top banks there is a verdict in
Scotland that there is not in England
and Wales it must be some kind of you're
allowed to protest provided you use
enough suit
no we're talking verdict here there is
guilty there is not guilty and there is
something else is it's not not proven
awesome young like that you're
absolutely right
Scots law has a verdict of not proven
which is that kind of we know you're
doing that you did it well lead
execution have not proved their case
beyond reasonable doubt is not proven do
that would hold out guy that was
actually it's just nobody had testified
yeah that's one of the reasons why if
the evidence is not sufficient but it's
circumstance carried it's gonna be nice
to see what this is about doesn't really
follow from what's just been said is
something so incredibly funny but
grossly inappropriate to the courtroom
and the prosecuting wedding we've got
him we've nailed an we've got a good
body of evidence or eyes for his honor
the sound of for who's forget it so the
cow was eventually taken to Aberdeen it
was sold for seven pounds the government
how did they do out of that deal oh and
they must have out the pocket on the
rail fares yeah you have to look to see
yeah because this is it's not just the
cows of famous cow that must post Ave up
a little bit a canny juggle it's passed
the bar and become a judge it's
diversified its skill set yeah you need
some little cows bodyguard there are
yeah a little things in there is dark
glasses all uncontroversial alone
getting it down to the market the
expenses he incurred or outrageous
really there were the high-class grass
you got shifted
she got shipped in yes you're absolutely
right the Sheriff's Department took a
loss on the whole thing uh what then
happened cuz this cow is in Aberdeen and
it's not been slaughtered for anything
yet got on the wrong train
little pinch Sheffield why because
that's how you probably transport a cow
at that time there's a full circle to
this story did you become a cow again it
was never not to count it was a judge
for a bit that doesn't mean it can't
still be forgot I mean you put a wig on
it who's to say what animal is that's my
defense approving because we couldn't
see it scalp exactly the farmer's friend
bought it back and gave it to him as a
gift yes you're right it was a list of
about ten different permutations I was
gonna go through yeah it's close enough
Briony Miller local girl and wife of the
farmhand rallied the local community
together bought back the cow and
presented it back as a major public
event ah did it was it in a box or did
over bow round paraded with Garland's
and ribbons and flowers
hey I'm painted with a slogan free
conduit we'll translate this from the
Scots because I can't do the accent
don't you wish you were me oh I'm a
juggling cow that's been a judge Oliver
like how are they doing all these messy
I mean does this paint rub off cows well
I'm from an urban environment of a
painted one chalk yeah do we have anyone
in the audience who has ever painted a
cow or know someone who might later
class version of County Bing averted in
my life to beef up Waitrose into the
conversation earlier like you've you've
gone up only because I've been alone
earlier about your biscuit and his
banana a Mike Watson he says do you want
anything from the shop I'm like yeah we
need some biscuits he's like yeah get me
a banana
yeah actually just said banana repeat
honey yeah and then he comes in he's got
a cross on don't don't get me about
middle class didn't it oh uh what
happened to the cow there's gonna be a
like if you want to visit the cow now
its skeleton is in the
is in a corner of the farmland yes it
was treated well for the vending years
was not sent to market after all and
eventually died a natural death and was
buried in the corner farm and you can
still pilgrimage to the corner of the
farm uh no but you can go to a roadside
monument in landrum ah that's good I
think I said no but you could stop on
the outside layer of the a36 three years
a bit of like trespassing later is there
a ghost of the cow by the lay-by a light
thing there is I like the idea that is
just a lay-by ghost because that's a
pretty crap ghost because you park in
the lay-by in the middle of the night
you hear a mooing so I was a county
about the cow goes how would you know
you've not seen the ghost of a cow deep
note congratulations Gary you in this
week's show you will a tool for combing
through puns to find male ducks signed
by a Canadian rapper
it's a Drake Lake Drake rake sorry it
looks like Drake signatures actually a
forgery there so it's a fake betrayed
collected
[Music]